humanitarian true steel between the Army
and the paramilitary rapid support
forces faltered on Wednesday at least
270 people have been killed and
thousands injured in five days of
fighting Al jazeera's hibber Morgan is
in Khartoum
fire Sheikh Khartoum
despite a ceasefire announcement the
fighting between the Sudanese Army and
the paramilitary rapid support forces
shows no sign of easing
the humanitarian cost is rising hundreds
of people have been killed and thousands
are injured
[Music]
Healthcare Services have been brought to
a standstill after heavy bombardment
Hospitals and Clinics are closed leaving
patients untreated ambulances have been
targeted preventing them from reaching
the wounded
the doctors had to evacuate all the
cases except the cases inside the
Intensive Care units there is a shortage
in staff medicine and oxygen the
hospital is witnessing a shortage in
many things even the doctors we have
left
the streets are eerily quiet people say
they're afraid to leave their homes
they've been dealing with strike on fire
others have been assaulted khalidosman's
mother was killed by shrapnel it was
actually a house in the living room
try to take shelter over there
when uh a sudden mortar
landed right outside their house and she
she called one of the shop Mills that
came from the motor and died almost
immediately
with no positive violence Sudan could
face a growing hunger crisis
three attempts at a ceasefire for people
to be able to leave their homes and
stock up on basic necessities have
failed and in the first hours of the
fourth attempt Heavy Artillery fire can
be heard in parts of the capital many
have lost hope of the fighting coming
down soon and are now focused on finding
Ways to Leave Her tomb to safety
those who do venture out are trying to
stock up on basic necessities
the violence is a power struggle between
Army Chief Abdel fattah al-burhan and
Muhammad hamdan degalo who commands the
rapid support forces once allies now the
two generals disagree about when and how
the paramilitary unit will be integrated
into the Armed Forces the last barrier
in the shift to a civilian-led
government
they dashed all the dreams of the youth
and the Sudanese Revolution the
revolution that started peacefully has
now became a fight I'm disappointed
both generals say they're committed to
the transition agreement and are blaming
one another for the escalation just
weeks ago there was a sense of hope that
long-running negotiations had succeeded
but now Sudan once again faces an
uncertain future Heber Morgan Al Jazeera
Khartoum
ID khalafala is from The tahriya
Institute for Middle East policy he says
that many people in the capital are
trying to flee to safer parts of the
country
we obviously sometimes need to leave our
houses to go to areas nearby to get
water because we have not water in the
pipelines have been cut for the past
uh when the pipes have been cut for the
past four days so we need to go out and
get water in addition to Food Supplies
and so on and would have been seeing is
a lot of vehicles uh will filled with
people and some luggage between the city
of Khartoum but also people fleeing on
food people just getting some luggage
and and walking and trying to find a a
way of transport to a seated City we
have seen also videos photos and news of
so many families who've left many of
them managed to live safely but a lot
where uh you know
killed or injured even
as they were trying to see the city
people are trying to get to a
neighboring states
down south to Algeria State and up north
to River Nile state where these two
states are relatively
safer than Khartoum and there isn't as
much uh fighting going on at the moment
obviously all the fighting is
centralized now around strategic
locations like the presidential Palace
the military headquarters and locations
where the rapid support forces
paramilitary are located uh within
khatum therefore also sees uh this is a
lot of violence these days but people
are trying to get to neighboring states
that are relatively safer for them at
the moment
Chad's Army has disarmed more than 300
Sudanese soldiers who crossed the border
Chad's defense minister says that it
doesn't want to be involved in the
conflict the government there closed its
border with Sudan on Saturday when the
violence began
on Sunday we had the Sudanese internal
security forces enter our home and when
we learned of it we had taken all
measures to disarm them we have four
hundred thousand more than four hundred
thousand Sudanese refugees who have been
with us since 2003. if it happens again
tomorrow you will see what consequences
we will suffer in this country this
Sudanese War does not concern us it does
not concern our citizens it's a war
between the Sudanese